hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
I'm Greg Alba as well okay before we go
into this I'm gonna make it super quick
I was a pretty huge fan of The Walking
Dead and I didn't really care for season
seven I got excited when I saw the
season 8 trailer and I did a stardust
review of episode 1 of season 8 and I
realized right when I was done with that
review that I am giving up on him cuz I
was like I am falling for any more
season one opening [ __ ] make me
think this is gonna be an exciting
season and then as more episodes kept
coming out the constant feedback I was
hearing was just how it's not getting
better and I was like I knew it is why I
was I can't I can't yeah and then
something finally got really spoiled for
me that I'm sure got spoiled for a lot
of you guys already we've already seen
it the spoiler video guys this big death
reveal Carlos is high
Karl loses his other eye Karl dies and I
was like about time and apparently
there's like fan outrage because they
thought you know we'll talk more about
it later let's just watch the video
[Music]
it was like Scott see this
[Music]
all Ricky Rick
or
[Music]
a weird place to get bit
[Music]
Oh
I guess I feel kinda bad for the kid
actually
[Music]
[Music]
don't shift this might make me watch it
again really yeah cuz watching the scene
and seeing Abraham Lincoln's reaction
made me go it's like that moment I tend
to stick around this show makes me sad
because because I love Rick and I always
want to see how he's doing but it's just
been so long since it held my interest
oh yeah cuz you got like 17 characters
on here and sometimes their episodes
that I don't even have Rick in it I did
give up on this show and I understand
there's like a lot of fan backlash
because of the way a lot of people
thought the show it was a little more
similar to the comics where Carl becomes
like the star yeah it seemed like it was
building to that that thought never got
me excited the thing is it's actors
named touchy and the rigs yeah rigs
Kyle Chandler's the other guy Chandler
Bing I think the guy is an okay actor I
think he's all right but he's not on par
with a lot of the other actors which
often makes his performance look weak
you could have a great Abraham you could
have a great Andrew Lincoln performance
interacting with Carl and then the kids
like doing what he's supposed to is he's
just not as effective I don't wanna like
insult the guys acting and be like he
sucks because a lot of people might go
out there and say that he just sucks but
I don't think he just flat-out sucks I
just think his skills are not as high as
everyone else's so I never got excited
about the thought of this guy being the
main star of the show and Andrew Lincoln
or Rick going away and I think the
overall audience reception has kind of
wanted Carl to go for a while which was
kind of surprising when there's this big
backlash I've almost never recalled a
time when people were like yeah Carl
that great Carl storyline like yeah we
usually seemed a dog on Carl so if
anything is gonna drift more away from
the comics by I mean Rick kind of just
being on his own now Laura's gone his
best friend is gone and Carl was keeping
him alive wait you only watch up the
season seven right you can even see the
season see when Glenn died now what's
the point what do you think would happen
let me see let me tell you if you're
right
what do you think how the plot of the
show
right when Glenn dies and all that
happens what do you think the show
becomes about Oh everyone's gonna be
like broken in spirits yeah like that
and then they're all gonna spend a lot
of time bumping into each other and
having conversations negan's gonna march
around and you know do wine because it
seems like they're more concerned with
really catering to the stuff that people
like yeah there's gonna be like a couple
cool Darryl scenes probably and then at
some point they're gonna be like now we
gotta overthrow this guy and not lick
his boots all designs and then you know
staged another war and it'll be like any
of their other war situations that will
end up in a weird oh and that guy with
the dreads and the tiger is gonna come
in somehow and that'll be like the
outside like Sarah he's insane so when
do you think Rick decided to finally go
up against negan I like late in the game
is the mid-season finale though really
by then yeah which it's because that's
what they do
yes that's why I escaped up on the show
they make their first midseason and
finale their best episodes but the
finale is when they finally go up
against negan I was like you mean to
tell me we waited a whole season for him
to just fight me and finally that was
ridiculous it's just a show that drags
everything out so I'm thinking with Karl
dying
I like disturbed emotional Rick I didn't
like Rick in the first half of season
seven where he's like a [ __ ] I like
Rick where he's like [ __ ] disturbed
and this guy's gonna like crack and harm
someone I love that side of him and
seeing his reaction there he was just
empty like just he couldn't believe what
was happening when he was seeing Karl
dying so I thought that was a great
reaction very authentic
I always like what he does like that's
the thing is whenever he's around this
show elevates and they do give him some
great stuff to work with I wonder if
they're gonna take this fan out cried to
heart in any way under nah they don't
care well I don't care oh yeah I mean I
might continue the show if anything I've
heard fear The Walking Dead's great now
and that's a surprise but it just seems
like it's really kind of meandered off
like I feel like since they've expanded
out into longer seasons now they ought
to kind of dial up the uncertainty of
everything and
of keeping people around for so long cuz
the first few seasons were striking
because you thought anything could
happen
you know yeah and characters were
memorable because of that well I think
it's why they killed off Carl yeah maybe
they're gonna start a new I don't know
guys is it worth it should I continue
this show this is the first time I've
ever just been like screwed it's been
spoiled for me I'm gonna watch the
footage yet tell me if actually could
see this show if it gets any better in
your opinion you can subscribe to the
real rejects please click that
notification bell you can download and
follow us on the Stardust app it's like
you know 30-second reactions and reviews
for any TV show film or trailer and
check out our patreon doing a lot of
music video reactions on there have a
weekly Q&A and a lot of other reactions
and we got some special videos coming up
soon on there so check it